What is [inaudible]?
Well,
toxicity basically describes the degree of adverse effects caused by substance.
So if something is more toxic,
it causes more adverse affects and something less toxic.
It the severity of adverse effect is lower if any substance can cause an adverse
effect.
If it's toxic.
There's three main types you should know which I toxicants toxins and poison
toxicants are basically chemicals so they can injure or kill humans,
animals or plants.
Um,
often re I related to manmade substances,
synthetic chemicals and things we tried to minimize in Green Chemistry toxins,
a specific subset just already produced by living organisms.
While we don't necessarily manufacture toxins,
we isolate them and use them as starting materials and intermediate.
And finally poisons a basically a type of toxin,
a toxic and that causes an immediate adverse effects will allow dot a little bit
about common toxins.
So there's a substances once again tonight produced in nature and often isolated
from plants and Fabian's algae,
other species.
So we've probably all heard a lot botulism toxin which produces paralysis.
We've heard about bacterial,
you could toxin which is offered to the cost of food poisoning.
Pretty much all of the world.
Finally ricing which is um,
isolated from castor oil,
uh,
and essentially acts by impeding protein synthesis throughout the body by
interacting with the RNA translational machinery inside the cells and making
them incapable of performing its normal functions as disabling homeostasis.
We'll now talk about some toxicants that are not naturally occurring but have
been produced by human activity such as as best as,
as best as a form of fiber,
often most common forms of crystal and fiber which is deposited onto your lungs
and when,
when inhaled is penetrates through your lungs,
is associated with cancer.
Over time,
lead in the paint is associated with a range of disorders including
developmental disorders in children.
And while led paint has been used in America for quite awhile,
it's not anymore in la contemporary issues,
there was dioxin.
Dioxin encompasses a range of chlorinated compounds which I usually persistent
the environment due to a byproduct of other reactions and can cause a wide
variety of negative effects.
And Dioxin has been a great example of unintended,
terrible consequences to human health and is considered one of the most toxic
chemicals in the environment.
And finally,
there's both federal aid has been been from childhood bottles because it is
considered to be an endocrine disruptor because it mimics the activity of
estrogen ends.
US has endocrine effects.
But,
um,
this,
there's some controversy on the subject,
and no conclusive report have really been issued by the EPA.